what better time than Christmas to
review a classic interview about whether
Jesus really existed with david
Fitzgerald from September of 2014 this
interview did really well when it
originally aired and I thought why not
this is the time of year to review that
interview so let's get to it David
Fitzgerald we spoke to him in September
of 2014 did Jesus really exist from a
historical perspective joining me today
is David Fitzgerald he is the author of
nailed 10 Christian myths that showed
Jesus never existed at all and the
complete heretics guide to Western
religion well David as you know we
talked about your book it was either
last week or the week before on the show
questioning whether the historical Jesus
even existed this is not a conversation
about whether Jesus existed as the Son
of God born to the Virgin Mary but died
and resurrected etc and the feedback was
crazy from people agreeing and people
disagreeing and people saying obviously
the historical Jesus existed so tell us
how you first came to question the
existence of the historical Jesus right
I mean 15 years ago it never even
crossed my mind that there might not
have been a Jesus it seemed ridiculous
ironically it wasn't until around 2000
that I got curious to know what is it in
the Gospels that he really said and
really did and how much of that is just
legendary you know baloney let's say
they just got added on later and so it
wasn't until I actually started looking
and trying to parse that out that I
realized first of all Wow our sources
for him are really shaky to begin with
in fact they really just boiled down to
the four Gospels and the four Gospels
really just boiled down to Mark's Gospel
which seems to be an allegory and but
I'm with you I'm blown away by how
polarizing this issue is among atheists
you know I get that Christians don't
like the idea it's kryptonite for
Christianity but it's it amazes me how
many atheists don't just disagree with
it I mean that's fine I don't have a
problem with that but how many are so
vociferous about it is all their
[ __ ]
arms go off and they oh this is like
Holocaust denial or this is like climate
change denial and really it's not the
same thing at all all right and then
just just so you know because we are on
broadcast TV and radio we want to avoid
the seven dirty words so let me ask you
this there are some supposed non
religious documents or pieces of
evidence that suggest that the
historical Jesus did exist so here's
just one of them and I'd be curious to
hear your take on it
Tacitus who is generally accepted as a
true Roman historian in his annals
mentions Jesus in a passage which many
scholars not all many scholars accept as
authentic regarding the Emperor Nero
saying the founder of this name Christ
had been executed in the reign of
Tiberius and there's some other examples
of this right which are certainly very
old references but they're presumably
non religious what do you say about
those right yeah those are all
legitimate references Tacitus Suetonius
Pliny the Younger all these ones are
mentions mostly they're talking about
Christianity but what we have to know
about that is when they mention Christ
they're talking about this figure
worshiped by the Christians now they are
talking about Jesus themselves and how
do you know that how do you know that oh
because you just look at the context of
what they're saying they're discussing
other things and this the the beliefs of
this particular cult happened to pop up
you know but what I want to point out is
none of them are contemporary with Jesus
these are all well into the second
century generations after after Jesus
none of them are making arguments or
pronouncements about Jesus himself they
just happen to mention him the figure
that is worshiped by these early
Christians we don't have any
contemporary references to Jesus during
his time or even close to his time well
what about what about what about they
lows from 55 ad right in the three part
history of the Mediterranean and again
even there it's not a direct reference
to Jesus as an individual but it's
mentioning the Eclipse that supposedly
happened
the date of Jesus's crucifixion so it's
it you're right in that it's not a very
specific reference but it is at least
only fifty five years later but here's
the thing about that even that reference
comes to us from a line a chain of
different Christian authors and it gets
changed what it's the meaning of that is
as it goes through each one but here's
the thing that's talking about an
eclipse it's the Christian commentators
on it who attach it to Jesus's date we
actually don't know what date
Jesus was supposed to have died we it's
a guessing game of even what year it was
depending on what years Pilate was in in
power and what days that if the synoptic
Gospels are right Passover fell on a
Friday if John's Gospel is right it had
to fall on the the the day after
Passover had to fall on a Friday the
Gospels disagree with themselves on that
but all these all these references
supposedly to you know
earthquakes or to supernatural darkness
at the crucifixion those are all just
eclipse accounts that Christians have
jumped on said oh look this must be
Jesus's Eclipse well we know one thing I
received a lot of was the desire for you
to respond to the claim and I got this
from five or six people who said David
asked David Fitzgerald about the fact
that there is more evidence for the
historical Jesus existence than there is
for plato's existence and this was an
interesting thing because many people
wrote to me about this has this become a
talking point around this is this why I
heard about Plato from so many that's
weird you know I haven't heard that I've
heard it compared to Alexander the Great
or Socrates the ironic thing about that
is they whether Jesus existed or not the
evidence that we have for him is so
shaky that for all extents and purposes
even if there had been a Jesus there
isn't one anymore but to compare Jesus
with anybody else in the ancient world
is kind of apples and oranges to begin
with first of all if we have bad
evidence for Jesus or if we have bad
evidence for Plato they don't have in
effect on each other but we should be
right to question Socrates for instance
because there's people who think that
Socrates was just invented by Plato
Homer is another great example when you
compare the evidence for Jesus and
evidence for homework
we know Homer was made up because when
we read The Iliad some passages talk
about bronze weapons some passages talk
about iron weapons so these stories are
coming to us over hundreds of years so
that argument sort of backfires on
people all right so again the book is
nailed 10 Christian myths that show
Jesus never existed at all we've been
speaking with David Fitzgerald David
very very interesting to talk to you and
I have zero question at all that the
controversy is going to continue on this
for sure if I can just say one last
thing this isn't a fight between
historicists and myth assists it's a
fight between historians who take the
myth Theory seriously and those that
dismiss it out of hand right or wrong it
needs to be taken more seriously